[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pourquoi tik tok se
retrouve-t-elle au centre de la guerre
commerciale entre les états unis et la
chine
tik tok est une application chinoise de
courtes vidéos fréquenté par près d'un
milliard d'utilisateurs à travers le
monde en majorité des adolescents elle
est depuis le mois d'août sous la menace
d'une interdiction sur le territoire des
etats unis
trump l'accusent en effet d'espionnage
et il exige que ses activités
américaines soit vendue à une entreprise
américaine
l'éditeur de logiciels oracle serait sur
le point de l'emporter le morceau
microsoft ayant été repoussée par les
chinois mais tik tok parle de
partenariats technologiques privilégiés
pas d'une vente
alors pourquoi tik tok on en débat avec
jean louis rocca qui est sociologue
professeur à sciences po et chercheur au
ceri le centre de recherche
international
avant cela vous avez dirigé entre 2006
et 2010 les ateliers franco-chinois en
sens social de l'université de tsinghua
à pékin vous êtes l'auteur de pieuses
leurs livres dont sociologie de la chine
à la découverte et la société chinoise
vu par ces sociologues
alors jean louis rocca est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quelques mots
on en parlera pendant toute l'émission
après mais pour vous comment expliquez
vous le succès de tik tok
c'est une c'est une une application qui
est extrêmement pratique à utiliser qui
surf évidemment sur le fait que l'on a
là un outil que les adolescents puisque
c'est en fait là le public principal de
cette de cette application ce sont des
adolescents est donc une usine est
vraiment quelque chose qui est très
pratique à utiliser qui est très rapide
qui demande peu de connaissances
techniques
et c'est quelque chose qui tout de suite
a eu du succès parce qu'elle permet on
pourrait dire une espèce de
communication non verbale
ce qui fait que à l'heure actuelle bon
les indiens les indonésiens un peu tout
le monde peut utiliser peut utiliser ces
éléments là donc c'est une application
je crois qui est un peu d'une certaine
façon universelle internationale et qui
demandent finalement relativement peu
d'ancrage dans un dans une culture
particulière c'est vraiment le monde de
la culture universelle et c'est ça je
crois qu'il fait le succès de
l'application
fabrice epelboin vous êtes entrepreneur
vous enseignez à sciences po la
géopolitique appliquée au cyberespace
vous êtes auteur de chroniques de la
folle ou de la foire que l'on trouve
uniquement livre électronique vous vous
l'expliquez comment ce succès phénoménal
l'année dernière en 2019 c'était
l'application la plus téléchargée juste
après whatsapp mais bien avant facebook
c'est la énième histoire de succès
mondial d'un système social sur internet
il y en a eu des dizaines comme ça les
plus anciens se souviendront de myspace
ou de friendster et puis évidente
facebook et puis d'instagram de snapshot
il y en a finalement beaucoup et chaque
année apporte son lot de nouvelles
applications qui connaît un succès plus
ou moins planétaire là là la vraie
spécificité de sel celle ci c'est que
d'une part le public est assez jeune le
jusqu'ici ce qui adoptait ce type de
technologie était un poil plus âgées
et puis évidemment aller chinoise ça ça
change absolument tout parce que je suis
si elles étaient systématiquement
américaine laurence allard vous
enseigner les sciences de la
communication à l'université paris iii
et vous êtes chercheuse à lire cave
l'institut de recherches sur le cinéma
et l'audiovisuel
vous vous l'expliquez comment ce succès
planétaire de type coque d'un point de
vue communicationnel tik tok les vidéos
tik tok présente une boucle voilà qui va
favoriser la répétition est supposé
permettre également de reprendre des
chansons voire aussi des paroles issues
d'autres vidéos ou issus voilà deux
des chartes des hit parades et c'est
donc ça c'est structurellement c'est
très favorable à la viralisation
essaieront que ça ça se partager ça
circule comme une petite ritournelle
comme un refrain populaire et ça va
populariser justement des slogans des
idées et tout un ensemble de faits
sociétaux malina reali vous êtes
responsable de la communication et des
réseaux sociaux médias d'opinion
indépendant le vent se lève qui vient de
publier l'histoire recommence aux
éditions du cerf vous vous l'expliquez
comment ce succès d'un service chinois
pour la première fois qui devient
planétaire alors tik tok a un avantage
compétitif par rapport à ses
compétiteurs c'est que comme le disait
laurence allard il fonctionne sous forme
de boucle ça veut dire qu'il est basé
sur l'imitation et ça ça répond à un
besoin très primaire de l'être humain
qui est celui de ne pas être seul
instagram c'est un réseau où on se
connecte pour désiré pour voir ce qu'on
a pas c'est un réseau de l'aspi
rationnelle au contraire tik tok c'est
un réseau où l'on se voir réfléter on se
sent faire partie d'une communauté qui a
les mêmes codes qui a les mêmes les
mêmes pratiques
et ça ça permet d'avoir un sentiment
d'appartenance qui a été
particulièrement important en ces temps
de continuer alors pour commencer ce
débat je vais vous montrer quelques yeux
quelques images qui viennent de tik tok
elles sont c'est plutôt du
divertissement sont plutôt des
adolescents mais évidemment il n'ya pas
que ça exemple
[Musique]
service client bonjour quand à votre
écoute et oui bonjour monsieur vous
appelle car j'ai un problème avec ma
boxe j'ai pu internet depuis d'accord
mais c'est donc si j'ai bien compris
vous êtes un problème de votre box si
vous n'avez plus internet depuis ce
matin c'est de créer votre dossier vous
transfère dans le département adéquat
est encore menacé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des semaines dans ta tu serais vraiment
la banane et ça je suis plutôt nordique
du coup je travaille surtout avec les
voeux et les puits
mon dieu patron ceo d'ing du coup bah
oui les ruines les incantations aussi
pour le coup mais pas trop la magie du
chaos tu vois si vous venez d'avoir
votre bac
ce message est pour vous d'abord pour
vous dire bravo félicitations
c'est le fruit de votre travail de votre
engagement
alors maintenant fêter le profitez-en
alors il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres choses sur tik tok vous
l'imaginez il paraît que c'est une star
réseau social particulièrement addictif
plus addictif que les autres vous l'avez
remarqué ou est ce que ce sont les
parents qui se fondent et des idées
comme d'habitude mais lena réalise ce
serait plus addictifs tik tok alors
l'algorithme des tic toc fait qu'il est
effectivement plus addictifs c'est à
dire que l'algorithme est plus puissant
que celui des autres réseaux sociaux
c'est un algorithme qui comme tous
fonctionnent selon pour faire des
suggestions
donc ces suggestions ils ont pour but de
vous faire passer plus de temps sur
l'application a donc vous faire revenir
plus de fois mais l'algorithme de tik
tok personnalise des contenus ce
beaucoup beaucoup plus vite et de façon
beaucoup plus profonde c'est à dire
qu'en trois like l'algorithme a déjà
compris si vous étiez là pour voir des
vidéos de danse des vidéos de cuisine ou
des vidéos de politique laurence allard
ben je n'aime pas tellement cette notion
de l'addiction puisque ce n'est pas
complètement une maladie le numérique
mais on va plutôt parler d'attachement
et cet attachement béa il est justement
design et par cette boucle
voilà qui va nous enfermer infiniment
dans des vidéos qui se voit là ce
apparaissent défilent sous vos yeux et
puis il ya l'algorithme aussi qui
finalement renforce des choix déjà
effectué donc c'est un algorithme peu
idiot en fait puisque bien il va vous
resservir des vidéos très similaire à
celle que vous avez scrollé à l'infini
voilà donc c'est de fait il ya un
attachement qui est créée par le
design la structure même de cette boucle
vidéo qui est vraiment typique de type
stock et qui explique son succès et les
attachements plus ou moins importants qu
elle qu'il suscite
fabrice epelboin g reprendre ce qu'a dit
laurent c'est important de pas faire
l'amalgamé entre l'addiction peut causer
une drogue et l'addiction que peuvent
poser ces interfaces est particulière
qui sont issus de la capte au logis
malgré tout il y à un phénomène assez
particulier qui se développe entre un
utilisateur et une application et il a
clairement il y en a un il est sur des
gens particulièrement jeune elle est
toute une population particulièrement
jeune donc ça aussi c'est nouveau il va
falloir qu'on l'étudié d'une façon d'une
autre parce que c'est pas nécessairement
très sain après le format de stack food
vraiment de tout petits contenu qu'on
peut enchaîner et puis évidemment cet
algorithme cette allégorie que la chine
refuse d' exporter cet algorithme a
visiblement un rôle tout comme il a un
rôle dans facebook il a un rôle dans
tout un tas de systèmes sociaux et on a
vu avec facebook que le la manipulation
de cet algorithme un peu des deux
pouvaient nous mener vers des
catastrophes
jean louis rocca oui alors on tourne
touche d'une certaine façon déjà là la
question des rapports entre la chine et
est là et les etats-unis et les autres
pays de manière générale parce que
précisément le la qualité de l'accord
eatm assez rapidement été utilisé dans
cette espèce de guerre pseudo
idéologique entre entre la chine et les
états unis autour de la question du
contrôle on pourrait dire sur les
adolescents américains
il ya eu aussi des histoires autour des
adolescents indien gouvernement indien
s'inquiétant un petit peu de du pouvoir
que pourrait avoir la chine sur ces sur
ces adolescents dont très rapidement en
fait la question précisément de entre
guillemets moi non plus j'aime pas bien
ce termes d'addiction est arrivée
rapidement dont on pourrait dire le
conflit où les conflits qui existent
entre la chine et
notamment les états unis mais pas
simplement les états unis alors
l'histoire la question qu'on se pose
c'est pourquoi cette application qui a
l'air particulièrement innocente
pourquoi elle excite à ce point la
méfiance et la convoitise de donald
trump vous avez une une réponse fabrice
epelboin je pense que donald trump avec
la ferc un budget étriqué acquis
maintenant et et publique est elle très
très bien placé problement le le chef
d'état le mieux placé au monde pour
réaliser à quel point ces applications
sociales peuvent être utilisés à des
fins de manipulation d'opinion publique
tant que toutes ces applications
sociales 1 étaient américaines les la
nation américaine pouvait s'estimer
relativement sécurisé bien que cabu
l'éthique a quand même causé beaucoup de
problèmes en amenant trump au pouvoir
mais là si on en arrive à un stade où
les chinois ont un contrôle d'une façon
ou d'une autre une capacité à manipuler
l'opinion publique américaine où les
jeunes américains effectivement on peut
comprendre que le président des états
unis soit a terrifié par cette
perspective tout ça s'exprime de façon
pas dire trump yens mais la crainte est
vraiment légitime et que qu'est ce que
vous a retardé par manipuler les les
adolescents américains
comment cette application peut-elle
manipuler mais adolescents américains
ouvrent bien muselé picard comme jessica
nous a montré qu'on était capable avec
ce genre d'applicatifs de saisir la
psychologie tout un chacun d'adapter un
message adapté à tout un chacun pour le
faire basculer typiquement dans un vote
d'abstention dans le cadre comme j'ai
été cas où un vote en faveur de trump on
peut imaginer faire ce genre de
manipulation à tout un tas d'autres fins
si on a vraiment si on commence vraiment
à utiliser ce type d'applicatifs pour
manipuler les esprits cas médiatique a
vraiment montré que c'était une piste
tout à fait envisageable est très
vraisemblablement efficace
si demain une nation étrangère pénètrent
sur le sol américain et prompt tout en
partie le contrôle de l'opinion publique
ou de certaines émotions collectives de
l'adolescence et des adolescents
américains où on est très clairement
face à un danger on a une nation
étrangère qui peut susciter tel août
le sentiment au sein de sa jeunesse
c'est vraiment potentiellement très
dangereux laurence allard vous partager
ce sentiment
c'est à dire j'ai reversé en fait la
problématique puisque trump s'est fait
manipuler par les adolescents via tik
tok puisque il ya eu tous les fans de
kpop qui ont acheté en masse des
réserves et en masse des déplacés pour
son meeting à tout cela en juin 2020 et
qui évidemment ne se sont pas rendus et
ont publié toutes sortes d'excusés plus
ou moins loufoques je devais garder mon
poisson rouge et c'est à travers tout un
ensemble de petites vidéos donc un usage
activistes et militants aujourd'hui de
tik tok aux états unis on l'a vu avec
blm le tagblatt livre matters utilisait
après la mort de georges floyd en mai
2000 le 25 mais 2020 donc c'est tram se
méfie parce que c'est lui qui s'est fait
manipuler par des adolescents en
l'occurrence engel en l'occurrence le
cas que vous citez
donc tu le sas et en juin c'est le
retour de donald trump en campagne
beaucoup d'utilisateurs de tik tok
réservent des places dans son meeting
tram d'ailleurs est très content il ya
des millions de gens qui vient le
veulent venir me voir
pas de bol en réalité n'avait jamais eu
l'intention de venir et ils se
retrouvent dans une salle de 19 mille
places où il ya peu vrai 6000 personnes
qui sont là et seulement 6000 tous les
autres ceux tik tok ne sont pas venus et
ils l'ont fait exprès mais là en
l'occurrence ce sont des adolescents
américains qui se servent du
d'applications qui s'appelle tik tok ce
n'est pas l'application tik tok qui
manipulent les adolescents américains
s'est pas exactement la même chose non
mme haidar et ali alors il est
relativement facile de manipuler les
opinions en montrant aux anges en ce
qu'il faut leur montrer pour que
changent d'opinion c'est à dire si on
montre à une personne qui est très
investi dans le mouvement de la glace
matters les positions pro police de
kamala harris
il est très facile de d'influencer son
choix de vote et pas de le faire voter
pour 30 mai au moins de ne pas la faire
voter aux prochaines élections donc en
fait il ya aussi un enjeu de montrer aux
électeurs potentiels de bain et de
harris qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
totalement convaincus de ce
choix pour la plupart des raisons pour
laquelle n'ont pas ils devraient voter
pour trump mais il devrait simplement ne
pas voter
et ça ce serait une façon relativement
facile d'influencer l'élection vous êtes
des corps jean louis rocca
je crois qu'il faut remettre tout ça en
fait dans une dent dans tout un tour
d'un ensemble en fait de dison de
politiques qui sont menées depuis
quelques années par les états unis
c'était l'objectif c'est que aujourd'hui
il ya une crainte aux etats unis n'est
pas simplement aux états unis de voir la
chine
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est à dire au lieu simplement d'imiter
la technologie d'attendre que l'on
veuille bien leur donner de la
technologie de pointe
ils sont en train de prendre des
décisions des positions fortes sur ses
marchés c'est exactement la même
histoire avec huawei aujourd'hui qui est
en pointe sur la 5g et c'est donc pour
pour la première fois on pourrait dire
on a vu là une économie qui sur le plan
technologique mais aussi financier parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent à gagner dans
ce domaine là et dans le domaine aussi
géopolitique puisqu'il ya effectivement
toute cette question d'influencé etc etc
on a une nation là qui remet en cause un
peu on peut dire le diktat américain
d'une certaine façon la chine enfin le
monde et les états unis n'ont rêvé c'est
à dire contrôler les électeurs et la
chine d'une certaine façon pourrait
réaliser cet objectif
donc je crois pas que la chine d'une
certaine façon fait quelque chose qui
soit complètement en dehors des
évolutions des processus technologiques
ou politiques etc etc
simplement la chine je crois dans
certains domaines a été meilleure et on
a la face face aux états unis
une puissance qui peut remettre en cause
on pourra dire l'hégémonie américaine
sur le plan technologique financier et
d'une certaine façon peut-être
géopolitique
fabrice epelboin si on si on vous suit
on devrait se dire mais alors parce
qu'après tout avant avant tik tok qui a
eu facebook il ya eu twitter mais
notamment facebook vous avez rappelé le
scandale cambridge et et analytique a
donc nous en france on devrait se dire
ben francillon facebook parce qu'il
pourrait très bien influencer nos
élections il n'y a pas de raison ils
peuvent nous manipuler parce que
j'imagine que facebook peut nous
manipuler autant que tik tok peut
manipuler les les américains donc
franciso facebook francisant twitter
francisant google aussi évidemment alors
que s'ils peuvent nous manipuler c'est
là ce serait la logique même nom
facebook est certainement beaucoup plus
avancé que tik tok pour ce qui est de
manipuler les gens il ya des des fuites
sur des expériences sociologique qui
sont faits à l'intérieur de facebook sur
sur des échantillons de cobayes de
plusieurs millions d'utilisateurs qui
montre que ils s'intéressent aux sujets
depuis plus de dix ans là-dessus il n'y
a aucun doute
et oui il ya un souci qui est que tout
ça pourrait être utilisé contre nous non
seulement par facebook mais par d'autres
acteurs utilisant facebook que ce soit
des d état étranger ou dieu sait qui il
est relativement aisé d'acheter de
l'espace publicitaire sur facebook et
d'aller viser des individus très très
particulier et à partir de là on peut
mettre en place des stratégies
d'influencé extrêmement fine visant à
faire dieu sait quoi diocèse où là
dessus il ya une trêve retrait véritable
opacité de facebook et les les débuts de
transparence qui a initié la plateforme
sont loin d'être suffisants pour
s'assurer que on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une manipulation qu'elle vienne de tik
tok ou de facebook le problème de
facebook c'est que entre instagram
facebook
whatsapp et tout un tas d'autres
applicatifs il possède l'essentiel de
l'univers social online alors que tik
tok
il a pour l'instant de connexion avec la
jeunesse ce qui est déjà inquiétant
c'est une nation étrangère que mettre le
feu à votre jeunesse avait déjà pas là
mais dans l'absolu pour revenir à la
france
nous ne sommes absolument pas souverain
dans notre
cyber espace social quand les français
échangent entre eux ils le font sur des
plateformes qui sont américaines et donc
ils sont manipulables par un algorithme
américains et on peut acheter leur
attention et détourner leur attention
juste en allant faire commerce avec une
plateforme américaine
donc ça veut dire que les précautions
que prend donald trump
au fond les les dirigeants des pays
européens devraient prendre les mêmes
l'égard des entreprises américaines
laurence allard vous le pensez vous
c'est à dire c'est le débat qui pense là
en terme de manipulation avec une forte
influence et un une problématique dont
l'histoire des médias et les théories de
la communication on relative et
relativiser depuis lors c'est à dire on
sait que les influences des médias et
notamment des contenus politiques et
indirects à dire ça va se faire par
plutôt de la conversation
interpersonnelles à partir de voiles à
d'un contenu politique qui a été
médiatisé ou kito qu'ils aient et c'est
donc cette voilà donc déjà ce cadre de
réflexion il pourrait être un peu plus
étoffé complexifier qu'en termes
simplement de même une manipulation et
influence directe et ensuite eh bien on
voit bien qu'il ya quand même des usages
qui correspondent à l'expressivité
sociale sur des problématiques racisées
problématique féministe et donc c'est
aussi un espace de prise de parole qui a
évidemment ses limites parce que il ya
toute cette voie là toute cette
machinerie technique à l'arrière-plan
cette boîte noire entre des algorithmes
des boucles et également des contenus
plus ou moins vraies qui circulent mais
il faut pas de voile à négliger cette
dimension d'expressivité qui n'est pas
que de la manipulation et dernière chose
l'audience et les usagers de tik tok
gagne en maturité puisqu'en france par
exemple avec le confinement vous avez
31% aujourd'hui qu'ils ont plus de 25
ans donc les sujets grandissent avec
leurs utilisateurs enfin grandissent en
termes de voix la deux en plus de prise
avec le monde tel qu'il est les
problèmes du monde
voilà donc pas non plus trop caricaturé
et simplifier le ce vaste débat
si je puis me permettre jean louis rocca
oui ben c'est ça me fait penser aux
débats sur le crédit social vous savez
on a beaucoup parlé d'eux des
expériences qui sont faites en chine sur
le crédit social alors on est
quelques-uns en france à avoir notamment
pierre sel et avoir avoir un peu été
regardée de près ce que c'est ce crédit
social et on s'aperçoit en fait que
c'est là la donne et disons de
consommation qui intéresse le plus
finalement la société chinoise et même
le gouvernement chinois et l'économie
chinoise c'est à dire ce qui est ce qui
intéresse les le gouvernement dans le
contrôle on pourrait dire d'une certaine
opinion c'est pas tellement les
questions de politique ou de même de
comportement social à la limite mais
c'est plus d'avoir des gens qui payent
leurs amendes des gens qui remboursent
leurs crédits des gens qui consomment
des gens qui savent gérer correctement
leurs économies et c'est autre chose
donc on mélange souvent beaucoup
beaucoup de choses c'est à dire bon on
pourrait dire quel est l'intérêt de
contrôler des adolescents de 13 16 ans
qui bon sens surtout intéressé par faire
de la danse chante et etc etc
et qu'elle est enfin voilà roues on a
tout de suite tendance quand on commence
à parler d'algorithmes et 2 et 2 et de
contrôle aux tours a effectivement de
facebook de parler de politique mais bon
les véritables pour l'instant les
véritables le véritable contrôle
politique je dirais à travers tous ces
systèmes là sont quand même relativement
limitée voyez on parle éventuellement
d'abstention etc etc
alors je dis pas que l'abstention est un
élément mineur et c'est bien mais de là
à penser que grâce à ces systèmes là on
va mettre les gens dans la rue où on va
contre au contraire obligé les gens à se
voiler ou à le faire je ne sais quoi
il ya quand même une marge de manoeuvre
parce que bon effectivement comme vient
de le dire laurence allard en même temps
tous ces éléments là sont des éléments
qui peuvent être prises en main par les
gens qui s'en occupent et pour des
usages qui sont différents et là il ya
effectivement comme elle l'a dit une
longue tradition de de manipulation des
manipulateurs d'une certaine façon donc
faut rester je crois prudent pour en ce
qui concerne 10 ont la capacité de
contrôle véritable de ces systèmes sur
le comportement et les représentations
des gens à l'ena reali alors comme vous
le soulignez les algorithmes ne sont pas
politiques en eux mêmes les algorithmes
se politise à usage donc le souci c'est
qu'on a créé un outil redoutable qui est
un outil commercial
l'outil pour vendre des choses aux gens
on a créé des réseaux sociaux qui font
que les gens reviennent on a créé des
collectes de données pour mettre une
publicité au bon endroit de la page pour
que quelqu'un achète et ça fonctionne
tellement bien qu'on s'en rend compte et
que certaines personnes veulent les
utiliser à des fins politiques
d'un autre côté la structure de boucles
qu'on l'évoqué tout à l'heure a aussi
des conséquences politiques c'est à dire
que tik tok crée des bulles de 6 litres
ou politique on l'avait de beaucoup
parler en 2016 pour les élections
présidentielles américaines dernière et
crée donc des bulles de filtres qui
amplifie des messages mais qui font
aussi que les personnes qui est serré de
publier des contenus politiques parlent
finalement à leur paroisse et bien je
vous propose de faire une pause et puis
on reprend ce débat juste après
[Musique]
il a été baptisé tout simplement france
relance d'une ambition et d'une ampleur
historique pour arrêter les les
croyances quasi religieuse sur le fait
que l'état donne une impulsion à
l'économie ça n'est jamais arrivé
quand on fait encore une fois un plan de
relance généraliste il ya assez peu près
si vous ne satisfait personne
sur les 40 milliards attendus de
l'europe on leur en donne sens et on en
récupère 40 donc sans moins 40 ça veut
dire qu'on est en l'air de 60 là où il
fallait mettre le paquet c'est beaucoup
plus sur les petites entreprises versus
très grosse et donc vous ne fait que
creuser encore les inégalités qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans nos pays
là il annonçant 60 mille emplois créés
mais on va en détruire combien
[Musique]
c'était une figure nationale il était
connu à l'époque quels étaient les
grands aspects de sa personnalité
gouda de la sablière donc sera un des
plus grands généraux donc de division de
la grande armée et ce général il sera
toujours fidèle
fidèle à la révolution aussi fidèle à l'
empire et s'il n'est pas populaire il
est respecté ça sans aucun problème
et lorsque il va être atteint par ce
boulet de canon le 19 août 1912
ça va être une grande perte aujourd'hui
français et russes main dans la main
pour retrouver les ossements du général
ghislain comment diplomatiquement cette
découverte résonne tel par mois je pense
qu'elle arrive au au meilleur moment
parce que je pense que les liens entre
la russie et la france des liens
historiques
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la fois la
convoitise et la méfiance que
l'application chinoise tik tok excite
chez le président américain avec jean
louis rocca avec fabrice epelboin avec
laurence allard et malina réels y
revenons à
à cette américanisation force et c'est
quand même quelque chose d'un peu
particulier puisque le président des
états unis a amené ces tic toc de
l'interdire aux états unis si les
activités américaines de tik tok n'était
pas vendue à une entreprise américaine
the lady au début de cette émission se
serait l'éditeur de logiciels oracle qui
serait en passe d'emporter le morceau
cette américanisation force et c'est
quoi c'est du protectionnisme
comment comment l'analysez vous fabrice
epelboin s'est annoncée comme un
problématiques de sécurité nationale
c'est pour l'instant un partenariat choo
entre oracle et tik tok qui consisterait
à donner accès à oracle pour donner des
avis d'utilisateurs américains
c'est techniquement pour l'instant c'est
absolument pas clair mais très
clairement c'est une volonté de
protectionniste de la part de donald
trump
sachant que il est maître en son domaine
jusqu'ici en tant qu' en tant qu états
unis sur tous les réseaux sociaux qui
sont utilisés quasiment partout sur
terre à part la chine qui a ses propres
systèmes et la russie qui a des choses
comme pk tout le reste de la planète
fonctionne sur du facebook de l'insta g
du syntsha des systèmes des technologies
sociales américaines
donc c'est vraiment ça que c'est une
première dans l'histoire de ces
technologies sociales pour la première
fois on a un acteur chinois qui sort de
ses frontières qui devient un acteur
mondial
on aura probablement doses à d'autres
acteurs non américains qui vivront cette
même aventure et puis ça va poser tout
un tas de problèmes sur tout un tas
nations notamment en europe
comment réagir face à tip-top comme on
repense et l'attitude vis-à-vis de
facebook
maintenant qu'on a ce cadre de figure de
tik tok qui pose vraiment autre chose
que des américains on a une nation qui
est très clairement hostile à l'europe
et qui maintenant va avoir une
implantation sur l'univers social des
jeunes mais pas tant que ça et de plus
en plus de personnes plus âgées
ça doit nous inciter à réfléchir à tout
ça mais je me souviens au début des
années 90 les américains s'étaient
rendez compte à travers un sondage et
pour eux ça m'était de ça avait été un
vertige terrible s'était aperçu que les
jeunes américains les enfants à l'époque
connaissait mieux super mario donc la
vedette des jeux japonais nintendo les
jeux vidéo que mickey et tout à coup il
s'était rendu compte qu'ils avaient
perdu quelque chose il a perdu une main
du soft power sur les jeunes enfants et
c'est vrai que de la jeune génération a
regardé peut-être plus de dessins animés
japonais que de dessin animé américain
mais là on était dans le soft power pure
c'est à dire que c'était des héros des
histoires là ce qui s'ajouterait et les
américains n'avaient pas parlé
d'américaniser les activités
nord-américaines de nintendo et d'autres
jeux vidéo
il avait même laissé les japonais
investira hollywood d'ailleurs donc on
se demande si là c'est véritablement le
contenu ou les fameuses données et
surtout l'algorithme qui les intéresse
c'est à dire qu'au fond et ne supporte
pas la concurrence
l'algorithme ils en ont ça c'est plus la
chine qui a trouvé ce moyen pour poser
des limites à l'exportation technologies
la différence avec l'arrivée des
japonais dans la culture de masse
notamment vers le jeu vidéo et les
dessins animés
c'est que là on est sur un espace social
on est sur un endroit dans lequel la
population va pouvoir échanger partager
des émotions s'organiser et jusqu'ici
enfin jusqu ici il ya encore quelques
décennies c'était quelque chose de
strictement régalien ça pouvait de toute
façon c'était contingenté par un espace
géographique
facebook a complètement changé cette
donne aujourd'hui on est plus juste sur
une espèce de culture américaine dans
lequel on âge et de toute façon depuis
bien longtemps
on est sur l'arrivée d'un autre acteur
qui est chinois et qui de par sa seule
nature chinoise doit nous posent des
questions sur qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cet espace social qui finalement
nous a échappé en tentation depuis belle
lurette
j'en ai rocha
oui alors si je peux me permettre tout
de même de re de remettre quelques
points en perd en perspective
bon on a il faut il faut éviter de trop
mettre toute la question du conflit
entre les etats-unis et la chine autour
de la question idéologique on met
évidemment de l'idéologie là-dedans bon
on n'en a pas parlé mais la chine et
n'est pas un pays démocratique avec des
élections etc etc on a toute une
aujourd'hui toute une pourrait dire tout
une opération intellectuelle aussi pour
montrer que les chinois sont vraiment
très méchant veulent faire des choses
terribles
etc etc bon je crois qu'il y a en avant
aussi une question d économique et
géopolitique
avant tout on est on est dans le soft
pas voir on est dans la question du
contrôle de ddd dollar pourrait dire du
cerveau des gens mais on est aussi dans
l'argent et on est aussi dans qui va
contrôler on pourrait dire les grands
moyens de communication et aussi les
grands moyens financiers parce que le
effectivement dit coque et un sera sans
doute très rapidement à une machine à
cash très très très important donc je
crois qu'il faut remettre ça dans ce
dans cette perspective et faire un
parallèle par exemple à propos de roy
ouais il ya quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire abordé l'histoire des
rois oui ou un ce moment les etats unis
font en sorte que huawei n'ai plus accès
à un certain nombre de composants de
haut niveau de high tech pour tout
simplement casser l'entreprise d'une
certaine façon sévère qu'on est dans une
situation où les entreprises américaines
et l'état américain essaye de choisir
finalement les entreprises les grosses
entreprises qui vont contrôler les
marchés futurs delà de la communication
alors omet évidemment de l'idéologie là
dedans mais enfin pour l'instant on
pourrait dire que ceux qui sont les plus
forts sur le contrôle tout même des
esprits même dans le domaine culturel
etc etc sont les américains c'est à dire
que pour l'instant les chinois ont quand
même une image une image internationale
extrêmement négative et
je crois que le gouvernement chinois si
vraiment il veut influencer la jeunesse
va avoir beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes
par contre tous les contenus que l'on
voit sont pas des contenus chinois sur
tik tok par exemple c'est un élément
important
c'est un contenu qui est lié comme on
disait tout à l'heure à l'expressivité à
la contestation même puisque le
gouvernement indien a beaucoup protesté
sur le fait qu' on voyait des contenus
qui choquait la morale indienne etc etc
donc je crois que ce fantasme un peu sur
le contrôle de l'esprit européen sur sur
la la la chine est quelque chose dont on
voit pas à l'heure actuelle le début du
commencement
laurence allard oui oui je j'abonde dans
le sens de mon collègue puisque en effet
il ya une application qui est qui avala
d'origine chinoise en termes de
propriété mais il y a des bureaux dans
différents pays et de fait il y a dans
les différents pays utilisateurs des
scènes plutôt nationale et à l'intérieur
même de cette ces scènes nationales donc
de ses tics top français parents ou
tic-tac indien il ya tout un ensemble de
via des tags bien choisis tout un
ensemble des espaces qui peuvent être
con comme on dit des espaces sur par
exemple pour tous qui va être minorité
sexuelle lgbt qui vit et c'est donc
c'est et donc voilà donc ne pas
surestimer le caractère chinois de tous
les usagers usagers de tik tok et il
faut savoir où va le tik tok est
extrêmement relié à twitter dans les
dents les dents les usa il ya un
glissement de ces micro scènes qui
peuvent être assez restreinte autour de
quelques communautés quelques tags qui
vous rend faire moins bien sûr dans
votre dans ces communautés
mais quand on veut à publiciser plus
avant une cause
un événement etc on va balancer comme on
dit dans la sauce twitter puisque
twitter c'est l'espace public numérique
le plus ouvert puisque il n'y a pas
forcément besoin de s'inscrire
d'ailleurs pour avoir accès à twitter
et puis les tweets son public
les certaine façon un peu par défaut
même si on peut à permettrait des
comptes privés et donc la routine pour
résister entre les applications et
twitter bon ben c'est n'appartient pas à
facebook 1 c'est ça reste encore twitter
mais il ya aussi donc entre cette
porosité entre une application chinoise
est un réseau social états unis on voit
voilà qui a également une dimension
transnationale des usages puisque on
n'est pas simplement dans un tick tock
chinois ou un un tweeter américain ça
passe de l'un à l'autre également et
c'est intéressant en termes de
géopolitique numérique en fait elle est
maire galli alors je suis d'accord avec
ce constat dans la mesure où il faut
remettre en cause l'influencé que peut
avoir tik tok en termes de soft power
pourquoi parce que tik tok silence et un
look c'est une coquille vide dans
laquelle les utilisateurs publient leurs
contenus un contenu qui est adapté à
leur leur culture nationale c'est pas
pour rien qu en france on retrouve des
vidéos qui reprennent les yeux de jean
marie bigard ou qui répondent à la vidéo
de jean luc mélenchon on peut
difficilement prétendre que c'est la
chine dans ces cas là qui influence les
utilisateurs fabrice epelboin vais vous
avez des doutes
oui j'ai des doutes en fait c'est plus
une incompréhension sur ce que j'entends
par de manipulation si vous prenez par
exemple le rapport du procureur mais
leur qui documente la façon dont le
d'armes et les trolls russe est
intervenue dans la compagne de donald
trump en 2016 pour diviser la société
américaine vous avez une multitude de
cas de figure où cette armée les trolls
russe a instrumentalisé le mouvement
black l'armateur en créant
artificiellement du conflit on
n'organise ont elles mêmes des
manifestations c'est par ce biais là
qu'on peut aujourd'hui arrivé à
manipuler relativement aisément sa
demande quand même certains moyens une
opinion publique d'un pays étranger
d'ailleurs pour on utilise un logiciel
américain ou un logiciel chinois
l'intérêt pour les états unis 6
ils font face à ce genre de
problématique c'est que ils ont encore
moyen de redonner à facebook de couper
certaines choses
d'ailleurs facebook passe son temps à
éliminer des opérations comme ça venons
d'une multitude de pays et d'acteurs il
est bien clair que les chinois ne sont
pas aujourd'hui à deux doigts de trouver
quelque chose qui leur permettrait par
le simple usage d'une application en
ligne de manipuler les esprits à travers
la planète
on en est très loin facebook certains
n'ont plus avancé dans l'autre dans
cette voie mais le simple fait que très
simplement on puisse aller interférer
dans l'opinion publique d'un pays
étranger doit encore une fois posé
question
tik tok est l'occasion honnêtement nous
posent des questions c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est plutôt
facebook mais tik tok du fait qu'ils les
chinois nous force à cette réflexion et
c'est honnêtement tout l'intérêt tik tok
est ce que disait jean louis rocca quand
il rappelait que il n'ya pas que tik tok
qui est dans le collimateur
il ya également laquelle a été interdite
c'est one shot
oui oui chat chat est interdite la loi y
est
et sur la liste noire on va dire c'est
quand même le deuxième fabricant mondial
de smartphones
là c'est les parts de marché que lucky
qui sont visés on vise la technologie
chinoise pas là ni manipulation des
cerveaux même si ea way on parle
d'espionnage également ah ouais ouais
très clairement les états unis cherchent
à détruire ou affaiblir une entreprise
chinoise qui est déjà un géant et qui
pourrait devenir un leader mondial
là c'est très clairement une guerre
économique oui chat c'est aussi ce même
problème d' espace social oui chat s'est
par ailleurs quelque chose d'extrêmement
complète il n'a pas d'équivalent de
monde en monde occidental ou authentique
toc
youtube vient de sortir une réplique à
peu de temps et on peut imaginer que
petit à petit les parts de marché à
équilibre entre ce type d' usage ou
autant lui chat et il est impensable que
qui que ce soit sort demain matin
quelque chose qui ressemble de près aux
liens à 8 chef sioui tchad venait à
s'imposer mondialement il ne pourrait
pas avoir de compétiteurs et et le fait
de l'avoir coupée aussi rapidement me
sens de faire dire que là pour le coup
ils ont bien senti que il ne serait pas
taille à lutter contre quelque chose car
oui chat sur les usages
jean louis rocca oui alors moi je
voudrais aussi noter que finalement on a
là à travers quelques exemples une
remise complètement en cause en fait de
l'économie capitaliste d'une certaine
façon c'est à dire que normalement on
nous a expliqué donald trump le premier
le premier qu'on a de la concurrence
qu'on a des marchés que les meilleurs
technologiquement doivent s'imposer sur
les marchés et puis on voit bien que
quand effectivement des opérateurs
réussissent d'une certaine façon à tenir
la dragée haute aux états unis et même
la dépasser tout d'un coup là on pense
en termes de démocratie où on pense de
termes d'influencé etc etc
donc c'est quand même intéressant de
voir le double discours d'une certaine
façon des américains mais pas simplement
des américains sur sur la question de
l'économie alors évidemment on va on va
dire ça touche comprenait le cerveau des
gens ça touche c1 mais bon d'une
certaine façon l'influencé est aussi un
marché mondial c'est à dire que
les américains sont en train évidemment
d'essayer d'influencer aussi l'opinion
publique chinoise et c'est pas nouveau
depuis des dizaines d'années il y à une
task force très efficace aujourd'hui qui
prend part un pack par exemple la la
forme du développement des églises
évangélistes en chine qui vise très
clairement à faire changer l'opinion
publique notamment des classes moyennes
et des ouvriers paradoxalement vis-à-vis
du gouvernement chinois donc
effectivement on peut les aider les
américains et les européens font très
bien se dire ouh là là ou là là c'est
chinois qu'est ce qu'ils vont nous faire
etc etc
mais je pense qu'à une certaine naïveté
de dire que les les gouvernements
étrangers ne doivent pas influencer les
ce qui se passe dans un pays intérieures
d'un pays
je veux dire c'est quotidiennement que
les choses se font dans tous les sens
d'ailleurs les chinois aussi interdisent
un certain nombre de choses parce qu'ils
ont peur que ça ça change les équilibres
politiques la façon de penser de la
population donc on est dans ce monde un
des influences et et sur ceux sur ce
plan là donc il faudra essayer de
montrer que les chinois sont bien plus
méchant bien plus efficace et bien plus
négatif pour l'instant disons qu'on n'a
pas les preuves du tout que on a sur ce
plan là une efficacité et une force de
frappe plus importante de la part de la
chine grâce à leur bain je suis heureuse
d'apprendre que les mobilisations contre
le raciste systémique aux états unis
elle fait 2 3 le russe ça me semble
quand même un peu extravagant gomme
comme hypothèse mais donc bizarre blague
à part hélas
en effet il ya un paradoxe de voir trump
essayer justement d'interdire une
application où il ya de la rage de la
liberté d'expression qui est qui a été
mise en faveur notamment d'une amérique
qui serait justement débarrasser de ce
récit sme systémique en faveur de
féministes qui serait qu'ils seraient
respectés
donc c'est intéressant de voir puisque
cette interdiction que trump on veut
faire peser sur sur tik tok parce que
justement notamment quand on observe
facebook ou même twitter vous avez une
conception de la liberté d'expression
qui est implémenté qui est très
étasunienne qui reprend exactement le
titre de votre émission c'est à dire ce
qu'on appelle la liberté négative il est
interdit d'interdire
et donc c'est cette idée que on va
proposer des plates formes d'expression
qui permettent un libre commerce des
idées et a même un concurrence des idées
et dans laquelle justement la vérité va
se va être fixée dans des transactions
qui sont justement de plus en plus
aujourd'hui compétitive concurrentiel
antagonistes et voilà donc ça c'est
c'est un peu paradoxal en effet devoir
krumm qui finalement au nom cette
liberté d'expression très particulière
qui de cette caractérisation très
particulière la liberté d'expression et
aux etats-unis bien voudrait interdire
en effet ce qui est une plate forme dans
laquelle une application dans laquelle
est bien il ya eu justement des opinions
contre trump qui on est et qui ont été
émises mais lena réalise donc on sait
que les les réseaux les réseaux sociaux
en chine sont très surveillées voire
même censuré tik tok n'est pas censuré
par les chinois que ce soit en chine où
chez nous alors tik tok est ceinturé par
les chinois en chine etc nous enchères
parce qu'il faut savoir que le tictoc
qu'ils ont un fils n'est pas vraiment
tik tok c'est un réseau social qui
s'appelle jean qui est séparé du réseau
du monde occidental si on peut dire et
c'est un réseau où il n'y a que des
chinois qui peuvent qui peuvent publier
justement pour pouvoir avoir la main sur
les contenus qui sont diffusées après
pour ce qui est du reste du monde il y a
eu des contenus censurer des contenus
entre normalement dès les positions du
parti communiste chinois
tous les contenus qui faisait par
exemple référence au massacre de la
place tiananmen
les contenus faisant référence à
l'indépendance du tibet et globalement
tous les contenus politiques qui
n'étaient pas d'accord avec les
positions officielles de la chine
étaient censurés officiellement tik tok
bien sûr ne disait pas que c'était de la
censure ils disaient qu'ils étaient en
train de supprimer les contenus était
susceptible de générer du conflit à
l'intérieur de l'application
parce qu'il voulait créer une communauté
positive une commune était bienveillant
du commune était sympa et qu'elle était
incompatible donc avec ces sujets
polémiques à bois et sa belle bois je
voudrais vraiment revenir sur le fait
que vous pouvez trouver en lit le
rapport du procureur mais leur effet
suite à l'ingérence russe dans les
élections de 2007 donald rhin où vous
trouverez qu'effectivement cette armée
trois russes un carnet aussi bien des
militants black light matters que des
milices d'extrême droite que tout un tas
d'autres choses de façon à très
concrètement mettre le feu à la société
américaine et c'est comme ça qu'on peut
relativement facilement avec
relativement peu de moyens influencer
l'opinion publique extérieure
et oui ça doit poser questions sur notre
opinion publique à nous français ou
n'importe quelle opinion publique bien
sûr l'influencent a toujours eu lieu mes
alliés de toutes façons a décuplé par
ces outils là et très concrètement le
fait que les chinois débarquent dans ce
jeu n'est pas le problème pour les
chinois les chinois démarre à peine
c'est pas le problème et chinois le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui on est
pour une large partie de l'opinion
publique baigner dans ses réseaux
sociaux
qu'on n'a aucune idée que très
clairement comment tout cela peut
fonctionner comment tout cela peut être
manipulée mais c'est que c'est manipuler
c'est documenté tik tok encore une fois
n'est que l'occasion nous poser ses
questions
le problème c'est pas les méchants
chinois mais chez moi sont à mille lieu
d'être aussi inquiétant que peuvent
l'être ne serait-ce que facebook
instrumentalisé par dieu sait qui
donc d'après ce que vous dites là est le
problème n'est pas tellement l'origine
de l'application hellman puisqu'en
l'occurrence les fameux trois russes
étaient russes héééé ont manipulé à
travers des outils qui n'était pas russe
tout à fait tout à fait le problème
c'est le déplacement d'opinion publique
dans ses outils et le fait que dans ces
outils ont tué semestre en scène
beaucoup de choses qui ne leur plaît pas
une réalité destinée à influencer
l'opinion
encore une fois c'est documenté dans le
rapport du procureur mais alors qui est
disponible sur le site de la ministre de
la justice américaine c'est très très
largement documenté et je voudrais
vraiment insisté sur le fait qu' on
n'est pas sur mon dieu les méchants
chinois débarquent on est seul sur mon
dieu les méchants chinois nous donne
l'occasion de regarder en face un
problème dans lequel on nage depuis déjà
plus d'une décennie
jean louis rocca oui bah ça rejoint ce
mot disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que d'une certaine façon les occidentaux
en rêvait et les chinois l'ont réalisé
d'une certaine façon ça on commence à
voir très concrètement parce que
précisément c'est quelle population
faire un pays qui est considéré comme
dangereux que l'on commence
effectivement à s'inquiéter mais je
voudrais faire une remarque par rapport
à plus globale par rapport à par rapport
à tout ça et attirer l'attention sur le
fait que la démocratie on pourrait dire
de manière plus globale est quand même
en danger quand on entend ce genre de
choses c'est à dire que la manipulation
d'un certain nombre de choses puisse
influencer des gens sérieux finalement
le là là je veux dire la profondeur
politique du citoyen
serait en train de disparaître d'une
certaine façon cela il suffira
finalement de mettre en place un certain
nombre d'outils que l'on pourrait me
pour pour manipuler et faire en sorte
que les gens votent plutôt comme si
plutôt comme ça alors effectivement si
on est dans ce genre de ce type de
situation on peut d'abord s'inquiéter de
la démocratie pour la démocratie puis
deuxièmement s'inquiétait aussi pour les
enfin en temps à s'interroger aussi sur
qui est responsable finalement de tout
ça parce que finalement ce processus
technologiques dont on parle ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui est tout à fait
nouveau un l'histoire de la
communication c'est l'histoire aussi la
manipulation etc
c'est à dire que on voit bien que que
les que les ai dit que les gens qui sont
en place que les grandes entreprises
sont sont complètement engagé dans cette
logique qui finalement commencent à
saper les fondements des fondements de
la démocratie est effectivement moi j'ai
été toujours j'ai été frappée depuis
quelques années par le fait que souvent
en aparté mais pas simplement en aparté
beaucoup d'hommes d'affaires français
par exemple regretté le retard de la
france vis-à-vis de la technologie par
exemple de ichat ou la technologie d'ali
baba etc qui sont aussi là des
algorithmes qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement avancé dans certains
domaines et est donc c'est assez
inquiétant c'est à dire que finalement
on dit oulala tout ça est dangereux
politiquement etc
mais finalement on a une certaine
ambiguïté vis-à-vis de la chine à la
fois il ya une certaine admiration
ils sont quand même fort ils font des
trucs nouveaux etc et d'un autre côté
ouhlala il réalise des choses auxquelles
on a pensé mais qu'on n'a pas réussi
réussir à faire donc je trouve que deux
années de façon là la situation est
effectivement assez inquiétante alors
d'un démo malone a réalisé une minute
alors il ya effectivement une double
morale en double jugement parce qu'on a
tendance à penser à la chine comme les
méchants de l'histoire aux états unis
comme les gentils alors que finalement
lorsque les états unis disent qu'ils ne
veulent pas de tik tok
ils ne disent pas que personne n'a le
droit de toucher aux données de leurs
citoyens
ils sont en train de dire qu'il n'ya que
eux qui peuvent toucher aux données de
leurs citoyens
finalement
question touche à la protection des
données à la souveraineté numérique à
l'ingérence étrangère sur la politique
nationale et touche aussi à des
questions de censure à qui est ce qu'on
laisse le choix de quels contenus
peuvent être diffusées et quel contenu
ne peuvent pas l'être
c'est donc globalement un sujet de ceux
de souveraineté et il est effectivement
regrettable que tout soit tout ça soit
résumé un conflit entre les etats-unis
et la chine où l'on n'a pas notre mot à
dire
il faut dire qu'on a abandonné toute
cette souveraineté il ya longtemps
dernier mot leur salaire ben c'est à
dire là on touche un petit peu à
l'ambivalence même de cette démocratie
en fin de de certaines démocraties en
régime numérique c'est-à-dire non de
fait on se mobilise on s'organise gilet
jaune les mouvements france
municipalistes les listes associative
etc s'organise via des plateformes qui
sont en effet la propriété de certaines
marques de certaines sociétés dont en
effet le commerce et est lié à allah au
traçage des activités qui s'y déroulent
donc voilà donc on est dans la on
utilise pour des usages démocratiques
des techniques des services qui ont une
limite au plan démocratique et c'est
toute l'ambivalence de savoir justement
bien poser le problème et puis de
proposer aussi l'alternative donc là n'y
a pas que facebook et twitter etc comme
possibilités et comme l'espace
d'expression possible donc il ya aussi
tout un autre internet qui existe qui
s'est développée depuis extrêmement
longtemps non et donc il faut aussi
parler lorsqu'on veut essayer de
démocratiser la démocratie numérique
je remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous remercie de
l'avoir suivi
et je vous donne rendez-vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]